Tesla is investigating how one of its
cars appeared to suddenly catch fire on
a busy street near Los Angeles cell
phone video shows flames shooting out of
the electric vehicle last week local
authorities say it could have been a
faulty battery but Tesla says it's still
too early to know exactly what happened
Jamie yuccas shows us how this incident
adds to the questions about Tesla cars
Tesla is calling the incident
extraordinarily unusual this Model S
quickly caught fire Friday afternoon in
West Hollywood California actress Mary
McCormack tweeted cell phone video of
the fire saying Tesla this is what
happened to my husband and his car today
no accident out of the blue in traffic
in a statement Tesla says our initial
investigation shows that the cabin of
the vehicle was totally unaffected by
the fire due to our battery architecture
which is designed to protect the cabin
in the very rare event that a battery
fire occurs well of course the video
footage itself looks looks alarmist
Alistair Weaver is editor in chief at
Edmunds there's obviously been some
issues with lithium-ion batteries in the
past particularly around cell phones but
electric car batteries are very
different there's a lot of sophisticated
technology Tesla maintains that it takes
extraordinary measures to protect
passengers from fires which it says are
at least ten times less likely in a
Tesla than in a gas car we've driven
over fifty thousand miles in these
vehicles and have never replicated this
or anything like it nor have we seen any
evidence elsewhere of other cars
spontaneously catching fire so I think
it needs more investigation other
incidents where Tesla's caught fire
involved collisions like this deadly
Florida crash last month or impact with
objects on the road like this 2013
accident in Washington State there were
no injuries in this latest incident and
Tesla says it is still working to
understand the cause of the fire for CBS
this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles